what's up GQ I'm Aubry Plaza and today
I'm going undercover on the internet
dude
let's check Instagram
evil hag Productions my logo I wrote
what would you like to see and then
dabberstein wrote the live-action Daria
movie that was very literal dabberstein
dabberstein knows the assignment I
played Daria in I believe it was college
humor that was back in the day but at
that point nobody would Finance the
live-action Daria maybe with me
unfortunately I had no foreign value as
they say in the business but look at me
now out okay this is a picture of me
wearing a witch hat I'm doing the
audiobook for the return of the
Christmas wish video occult commented
how many witch hats do you own I hope
it's a lot smiley face all right that's
the creepiest [ __ ] I've ever read what
do you care how many hats I own the
answer is I own a lot of them in all
different kinds of colors and levels of
power from my new cartoon little demon
airing on FX every Thursday night Mr
panicky says be honest dot dot dot is
this based on the true story of your
childhood no judgments here only
curiosity
yes
[ __ ] it posted Reddit oh God I'm scared
of Reddit I'm scared I'm scared I don't
want it
flat appearance 525 says how did Michael
Kane wind up in a movie with Aubry Plaza
that is as random as you can get why
we're both actors why
flat appearance how did you end up with
such a flat appearance that's random
Michael Caine taught me a very
um I hate to say it because I don't want
any of my competitors to know this trick
but I'm just going to do it Michael Kane
taught me that when you're in a close-up
in a movie look at the camera with only
one of your eyes and then the other eye
is left for the audience he says
did I get an Oscar you did yeah okay it
works every time I didn't really teach
him anything but I did roast him an
entire turkey and that was a real
interesting night in fact he walked up a
couple flights of stairs to get it in
the dead of winter in Montreal that's
something it was close to Thanksgiving
enough that it made sense to roast a
turkey I wouldn't just you know randomly
roast a turkey you know in April not
with my cocaine now I'm looking at a
picture of myself from very recently
which is very suspect because this just
happened I just bought this sweater
Akiva vasha007 says if they did a sequel
show movie with an adult Wednesday and
couldn't get Christina back Aubry would
be my first pick for Wednesday I love
Wednesday Adams I love Christina Ricci
but unfortunately I'm more in the
Morticia casting pool at this point but
if they did like a newly divorced
Wednesday going on a wellness retreat in
Arizona I'm pitching a movie right now
this is gold I need to call Tim Burton I
want to see a movie starring Aubry Plaza
which one should I watch first go
backwards start at Emily the criminal
and then make your way back black bear
anger Goes West best sellers okay I'm
gonna stop Twitter Twitter
#now watching Donald Glover Aubry Plaza
and Ellie Kemper in some of their first
roles ever question mark question mark
question mark how have I never heard of
this question mark question mark
oh
look
up
he blew into my mouth Donald Glover and
I were in the same class at NYU he did
blow into my mouth in the movie
cornflakes girl Aubry why do you hate us
so much please respond [ __ ] off I don't
hate anybody there's a tweet Above This
that says from Debs know me is it really
evil hag retweeting all the Emily the
criminal tweets or her team I already
saw it yesterday by myself and I need to
watch it again soon with all my friends
it's really me I I tweet myself I
wouldn't even know how to have anyone
else do it because I don't remember the
password
I have two kinds of fans one fan that
hates me and I hate and we pretend that
we hate each other but we love each
other and then I have another kind of
fan that is a baby hag and I'm I guess
I'm mother hag and they're my babies and
they live in a cave covered in seaweed
and the Third Kind of fan that I have is
the one that wants me to run them over
with a car or punch them in the face
next verified account at Joanna Robinson
writes New Amber mid Thunder fans go
watch Legion all caps Jr responds when
will her and Aubry Plaza play sisters it
needs to happen mange maker said what
about nemes sisters I love Amber mid
Thunder yeah I guess we do look like I
never thought about it when we were on
Legion it can be fun to to fight and
then it's kind of a tie and we have to
join forces y'all gotta write it and
then we'll do it all right let's see
some YouTube comments
we all know about YouTube Here's a meme
from Parks and Recreation Matt's crazy
art says okay not surprising Rashida
Jones could sing since her dad is the
best music producer ever but who knew
Aubry Plaza could sing just as well
first of all Rashida Jones can sing but
not because her dad is a music producer
she talented I can sing in character if
you give me a character and you give me
a motivation I'll sing my heart out
Colton does she improvise some of this I
don't see how a writer writes some of
this stuff LMAO we would do what's
called a fun run where we would do the
script and then we would do a fun run
where we could say whatever we wanted
and a lot of times the fun runs made it
on on the show especially in the early
Seasons fresh says is she playing a
character or she genuinely like this 24
7. either way she's hilarious am I like
me 24 7 oh God am I genuinely like this
what is this you get up here and do this
and see if you don't act weird fresh
from my recent stint on the MLB Network
George Stevens says great swing why do I
get the feeling she's used a bat before
well George I've used a lot of bats I
picked up a bat before I could walk
George I play sports a lot I like to
shoot hoops I'm working on my golf swing
I like to swim I'm competitive swimmer I
like to play volleyball most recently I
crush it in a shuffleboarding game in a
dive bar some somewhere it doesn't
matter where so you can find sports
anywhere and that's the thing I love
about sports I've never heard of quora I
don't know who she is or what she wants
but I'm about to find out
[Music]
what do you expect from the White Lotus
season 2 uh well quora
expect that some of my scenes will make
it in the show I hope is this this is a
trick Cora is tricking me we did get up
to a lot of nonsense
this is just between us right I did a
couple pranks on Adam DeMarco Adam
DeMarco sorry that I psychologically
damaged You by putting a Blair
witch-like stick figure in your room and
then convincing you that it wasn't me
even after you saw the security camera
footage that identified me
is Aubry Plaza going to play Catwoman
first of all I'd love to I'm more
focused on the Joker there's never been
a female Joker has there and there's
something about that that's a little
more interesting to me what do you think
of Aubry Plaza's Lara Croft and then
there's a picture of me next to Lara
Croft I'm down I would love to be Lara
Croft I love action stuff moving around
getting all sweaty and dirty I love
rolling around in dirt
does that answer your question posted
Wikipedia Wikipedia
Plaza was named after the song Aubry by
Bread sometimes Wikipedia gets it right
my mother was really rocking out to
bread and in the 70s 80s 80s I was born
in the 80s I was born in 17
. they grew up very Catholic in a very
Catholic household and said the
combination of that and movies is her
favorite thing ever talking about her
love of Christmas and movies I totally
blacked out when I read that I don't
even know what I read this is like
someone that did a lot of mushrooms and
then like tried to write something yeah
I grew up in a Catholic household not
bragging or anything favorite thing
about Christmas is Christmas movies and
Santa Claus cookies
okay that's it I'm done humiliating
myself and learning a lot about myself
thank you so much goodbye
[Music]